and welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody so we are continuing our
coverage at the Idaho College student
murders where four students were
murdered in a home not far from the
University of Idaho campus and Jeanette
Levy and I hosted a live q a during the
lunchtime hour on Long crime Network
Wednesday addressing some of the biggest
questions that you have out there and
one of the critical ones was why is it
taking so long for police to release
information that is something that is
frustrated the parents of one of the
victims Kaylee gonsalves her father has
hired a private investigator to look
into Kaylee's brutal murder as well as
suspects that he claims the police wrote
off too quickly and he's also planning
to hire an attorney to try to force the
Moscow Police Department to turn over
documents and evidence related to the
case on Tuesday the Moscow Police
Department released a new report on the
information coming in from the public so
there have been more than get this
2500 email tips 2700 phone tips and
another thousand digital media
submissions that is a lot to sift
through but Kayla's parents have done
interviews with media Outlets saying
that they need more information and that
they deserve more answers veteran FBI
special agent Bobby Chacon took part in
Wednesday's q a and I asked him if
hiring professionals like lawyers and
investigators will help or cause more
problems
the lawyer will help them navigate the
processes that are available to them as
families of victims there are a lot of
victim witness statutes in certain
states that help the families and
Witnesses and victims
um kind of navigate the process of how
we get compensation or how we get
information and so those things can be
kind of you know onerous sometimes and
so an attorney who specializes hopefully
in that area can help them navigate the
paperwork that they fill out and the
processes of what they can get and how
they go about getting it hiring a
private detective I'm not a big fan of
um they sometimes start parallel
investigations they talk to other
witnesses that you've already talked to
and that can kind of complicate and
interfere with the investigation I was
never a fan of that when I was working
on the inside as an investigator me and
the prosecutors would be working towards
things and when someone else is out
there talking to witnesses that we've
already talked to or you know that's
that's that was problematic to me
Brian it's interesting because when we
discussed this you said that having an
outside investigator in a case like this
is kind of like a dual-edged sword why
do you say that it's a dual-edged sword
in the sense that as much as you're
helping the case you could be hurting
yourself as well depending on how you
wield that sword now Bobby's correct
that's kind of the concept of too many
chefs in the kitchen everything gets
burned if you have an investigator
running a parallel or intercepting an
investigation they can kind of stumble
on each other but depending on how this
investigator goes about they could
actually reach out to witnesses that the
law enforcement never knew about I know
in New York especially in other states
depending on the relationship between
the police and the community sometimes
people will speak to the investigator of
the family because they're sympathetic
to the family needs more so or quicker
than they would to the police but if
they work in conjunction or together it
could actually be helpful yeah and we
know that Mr Gonzalez has identified who
the private investigator is but that it
seems to be someone whose former law
enforcement Terry I get the frustration
I completely do but just frustration
equal legal liability because part of
the things that I wonder is do you think
that any of the parents are going to end
up suing the authorities for the way
they're handling this case well I hope
that doesn't happen and it might be
but they could they could actually say
that they mishandled the case you know
initially they said that the individuals
were targets then they said the building
was targets they also have been as the
father said they have been dismissing
people very quickly as suspects and
perhaps they should have been following
that up so I do think that they could
have some claims here maybe they
mishandled some of the evidence that's
in that house by allowing some of the
personal belongings to be taken out so
you could claim emotional distress you
could claim negligence you could even
try to make a claim for a constitutional
right but let's just hope the police are
able to get all the answers and and it's
premature right it's premature to think
this at this point but it's something to
consider nonetheless parents in Idaho
are pleading for answers As Time
stretches on and any substantial
information from police has not been
very forthcoming so here's what we do
know so far about the case we know that
six people were inside the home on
November 13th when four of them were
killed Kaylee consent Alvis and her best
friend Madison Mogan Zana kernodle and
her boyfriend Ethan Chapin all died of
stab wounds the two others on the ground
floor of the home may have slept through
the entire thing the police department
and prosecutor's office have released
conflicting information multiple times
and they've had to backtrack or clarify
statements so where does the
investigation currently stand
we're at that point in the investigation
we're still gathering information we're
still Gathering tips we're still
Gathering evidence we're still doing
everything we need to do but there also
comes a point in time when the family
needs to have those belongings back the
ones that we can get them back they've
asked for some of those things back so
we're ready to take care of that for
them
and as you just heard on Wednesday
officers did move boxes of personal
items from the crime scene loading them
onto a truck long crimes and Jeanette
Levy is in Moscow Idaho digging into the
police response as well as the
possibility of evidence being
compromised
Moscow police are planning to return to
the home here on King Road to retrieve
some of the personal belongings of the
victims of these homicides the police
chief says that he wants to be able to
return these items to the victims
families
police hauled boxes of belongings out of
the home chief James fry explained why
he and his Command Staff removed these
personal belongings
we're going to be getting that those
items back to the families it's time for
us to get those things back that really
mean something to those families and
hopefully to help with some of their
healing the house at 1122 King Road
remains in active crime scene secured 24
hours a day it's been processed for
evidence but it raises the question
could going back into the home
compromise any evidence remaining
retired FBI agent Bobby Chacon weighs in
everybody that comes across that yellow
tape is logged in when they were there
what they were doing there where they
went within the scene itself and and if
they can maintain that kind of control
um sure I think that they can do this
properly without damaging The
credibility of the or the
um the the Integrity of the crime scene
King Road was the home to Maddie Mogan
Kaylee gonsalves and Zana kernodle
zanna's boyfriend Ethan Chapin was
staying there for the night more than
three weeks later there's still no
arrest and no known suspects
Moscow police described this
investigation as very active they say
they're still getting test results back
from the crime lab and continuing to
sift through thousands of tips reporting
from Moscow Idaho I'm Anjanette Levy for
Law and crime daily
all right my co-host Brian buckmeyer
joins me joins me now Brian you're a
public defender you know what these
families go through it's just
unimaginable right it's so tough It's
the combination of not knowing but
needing to grieve and allowing a family
to grieve while leaving no stone
uncovered in an investigation with no
suspect is difficult on one hand turning
over personal items that the family
wants and should have is important
photos clothing or personal items that
the victim's family may want so they can
reflect on and remember those victims
are things that are likely to be turned
over but the difficulty is knowing
whether or not these items have any
value to the investigation each of these
items that are going to be turned over
need to be photographed tested if
possible and cataloged before so because
you never know what fact down the road
is going to make something that they may
be turned over or didn't look at that
much more important to the case the hope
is that the police are dotting their
eyes and crossing their T's so that no
lead is lost as a family is given space
to grieve yeah and let me bring in
co-host and former trial Attorney Terry
Austin into the conversation to so Terry
we know that most cases their work from
the inside out so that may be why the
authorities are focusing focusing so
much on the crime scene but what else do
you think Authority should be
investigating you know they definitely
have to follow each and every lead not
just for the suspect but they also need
to look at each of those victims and
follow those leads out so we know for
instance that Ethan was a member of a
fraternity were there any people there
who had a problem with him make sure
they followed that up and as far as the
other victims are concerned did they
have any other affiliations did they
have any arguments what was their
relationship with their family so they
have to go as far as they can with each
of those suspects from the inside out
and once they get out follow those leads
as much as they're following the leads
inside that house inside the house
clearly has DNA evidence clearly has
evidence as far as you know a timeline
is concerned but they have to do the
outside investigation too and remember
we have a timeline for where they were
the night of this incident so we need to
look at what happened when they went to
that bar what happened when they went to
that party was there a problem there
right and and just because we don't know
what they're looking into doesn't mean
that they're not going through all of
this behind the scenes